hello there it's update day once again
in the world of fortnite the live event
is being set up before our eyes and the
story is moving forward and we also have
those important inanimate objects to
follow around too i'm adam marrow here's
my creator code let's break down the
island's secrets during week nine and
ten
io have officially made their move a
brand new poi has appeared on the lake's
shoreline the collider i wonder how many
people literally collided into it to
discover the name a huge spire of energy
pulses and pushes back anyone who gets
too close last week the origin strapped
a center pack to our backs and sent us
looking for this orange energy this is
undoubtedly the same juices flowing in
the collider right now remember that
loading screen a few weeks ago we were
right to look into that sloan was indeed
holding a model of the collider
according to the leakers although they
haven't been confirmed the event will
take place on friday june the 3rd just a
little over two weeks away oh just give
me a sec random myth chasing moment what
happens if we eat ourselves directly
into the collider oh
well that happens here at the collider i
o have set up some sort of dam it
completely stops the water running out
of the lake which means sanctuary and
sleepy sound their water levels are in
question but what do i o want with the
water does it power the collider are
they deliberately trying to keep clean
water away from the seven and their
allies all river beds to the right of
the collider now run completely dry and
last time we saw a doomsday machine mess
with water it became a tsunami
before we move on from the collider take
a look here and you'll see a supply drop
i've tested this a couple of times and
it was there both times but i'm not sure
if this is a 100 certain supply drop if
you test this and it works for you could
you let me know in the comments please
i'm working on a structured storyline
video for the season but like usual
there's a few things more important than
others if you want a really quick way to
get back up to date with the story
here's the top three things you should
know there is a divide between the
members of the seven and the paradigm it
seems the paradigm broke out of an
impossible i o prison which leads others
to believe she is somehow aligned to io
and other members speak of something she
has done which is simply catastrophic
although we're waiting for evidence
point two john d is trying to use his
former i o credentials to hack into
secure files on the i o servers all
about the seven and for some reason the
files on the sisters are missing the
imagined and the order he cannot find
any info on those at all this looks to
be setting us up to be double-crossed by
the sisters and the last time someone
mentioned the sisters they also
mentioned jano
i can get you to jenna
and the sisters i can get you all of
them we'll talk about him another time
and now the most mind-blowing piece of
information today we learned that the
giant mech is coming back long story
short the seven is recommissioning the
mech and we don't know if paradigm will
pilot it the seven want to rebuild it to
try and take on io head on but here's
another issue because of how disliked
and mistreated the paradigm is she may
not return ever but every cloud has a
silver lining this could be our chance
to become the seventh pilot in a live
event imagine that a live event in only
a few weeks
let's follow the riverbed to sleepy
sound and you will find a familiar
friend over by the lighthouse it's peely
the retired 7 agent is now the
resistance haulage driver we've seen him
crash an ice cream van we've seen him
crush a bus and now peely wants to drive
this lorry cab this semi truck whatever
you call it go talk to him and the
caption reads peely looks over to the
truck beaming with confidence if you
reply with you want to drive the oh no
he'll strike a hero pose and mime
honking the horn if you choose to
believe in him he'll cry banana juice
tears in happiness and yet we all know
what he'll do next he's gonna go
straight down the road and into this
pile up just outside kony which has
actually been updated this week it's had
another car added to it four cars and
the bus now sit here waiting for a truck
to be added to this anytime soon and i
think it's time we said what we think
this is going to be imagine that bus was
a body the cars were legs and arms and
the truck cab would be a head and what
do you get oh yes truckasaurus is coming
back chapter one oh geez rejoice the car
monster from the trailer park could be
coming back to fortnite and it's all
thanks to a man-sized banana here's my
guess petey lifts the slurp trailer out
of the water with the crane and connects
it to his truck everything's going fine
he then crushes because that's what he
does into all those other vehicles and
thanks to that mythical slurp juice
truckasaurus somehow lives he then
becomes another side story and slowly
moves around the map each update i may
be getting a little ahead of myself but
i do hope that's what happens anyway
what did you call this guy back in the
day the transformer optimus prime maybe
or truckasaurus
a few days after the last update a
sudden change occurred at the impossible
rock another container was raised and
the structure became frighteningly high
we thought it must be the end but epic
was like hold my slurp juice and this
week they added the almighty pink
container just take a look at this thing
a rock precariously sitting with one two
three four five six heavy containers
upon it this place cannot survive the
season and as everything is returning to
something from chapter one what if this
monstrosity of brilliance here became
the containers from season zero
remember those let's check back again
next update it's time to look over our
family the rock lords of the fortnite
island
they've been buried they've broken free
they've embraced they've tried to cross
a road and now check it out they found a
home a new farmstead for the whole
family there's a few teething troubles
like the dog is stuck on the roof and
their dad can't get him down right now
and the kid has run off to play he may
be climbing that tree or someone may be
getting a coconut to the dome sharon
stone is planting out the first crops
for the new family and his new beginning
they're doing all right to say they've
been buried in sand for years gg's all
round hey wait did you see that that
statue moved i saw it drop the cabbage
one of the most interesting updates this
week sees io stronghold at the cavern
slightly growing again and a new bunker
door sits firmly shut completely unable
to open thankfully it isn't like chapter
2's bunker we can simply sneak inside
using the oversized air vents nearby and
this is the room some kind of hauler
table for planning an attack may be or
it could just be a budget reality
stargate is anyone old enough to know
what a stargate is nope just me i'm old
in the replay files look around in this
room and you'll see some interactable
things but right now they aren't in game
so it looks like we have to wait another
week to fully understand io's war room
as it's week nine my job is to run to
the cactus field and count up all the
cones left by the hooligans a month ago
our theory was each update more cones
are added to represent the weeks so
let's do this it's week nine today so
there should be nine let's count one two
three
four five six seven eight nine the
theory is confirmed the cones do indeed
indicate the weeks in the season
brilliant i salute you fortnight dev for
the super tiny updates right how did i
do i think i got everything oh i should
make sure we state that the blimp that
was over tilted fell into the lake over
the weekend and not on the usual tuesday
the seven are now fully in control of
tilted and their flag flies to show
their dominance all the star wars
content has been heated which means no
more star destroyer in the sky and all
the outposts have gone they've all gone
back to serve the empire and no more i o
for them right i'm gonna go get to work
on that storyline video because this
season is so crammed with missable
information thanks to the challenges so
hopefully i'll get that finished this
week i'm adam here's some legends from
three weeks ago who used my code i know
i need to do better replying to people
who use code adamaru thank you very much
for supporting me it really helps i'm
adam you're awesome i'll see you next
time
[Music]
you